for months I've been talking about what
seems to be kind of a pressing desire
from Donald Trump to bomb North Korea
because it would really serve so many
purposes that to trump
according to Trump's own internal logic
would be really important bombing North
Korea might make Trump seem strong and
powerful and it would prove that he has
the biggest button I think is what he
used to refer to take attention away
from the scandals right the lack of
accomplishments of the Trump
administration and then on some level a
nation at war at least initially right
in the long term it didn't quite work
out for george w bush but at least
initially a nation at war
whatever that even means in 2017 often
will rally behind the president which
might help Donald Trump's approval
rating woes which are not going away but
he hasn't done it yet right Donald Trump
hasn't yet struck North Korea and we may
now be learning why because according to
new reports in the Telegraph and The
Wall Street Journal it's been Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson and Secretary of
Defense Jim mattis who have been urging
Trump not to strike North Korea
something that by all accounts he has
wanted to do 100% as we imagined was
going was going on in his mind and
interestingly these reports say that
Donald Trump's national security adviser
I like to call him the not yet indicted
Michael Flynn HR McMaster he reportedly
is in favor of striking North Korea he
wanted to do what's called a bloody nose
strategy that means that when North
Korea does one of their typical
provocations you immediately and sharply
lash out and violence and the analogy of
calling it a bloody nose strategy is you
punch someone in the nose immediately
when they insult you for example to show
them that you're not going to be pushed
around or something like that I guess
and these reports also are renewing
allegations that Rex Tillerson approach
is really not pleasing Trump very much
and there's every indication that Rex
Tillerson is still on thin ice we
recently heard there was a CNN interview
I saw a few days ago where one out
analyst said Tillerson is not
to last through 2018 now Tillerson when
asked said he has no plans to leave but
saying I have no plans to leave is
different than I can guarantee you I
won't be fired but that's sort of a
sidebar to what we're talking about here
which is North Korea the truth is
Tillerson and Jim mattis are correct to
be cautious because in the end North
Korea does have nuclear weapons whether
they are telling the truth or not that
they could strike the u.s. or US assets
or US allies it's actually kind of
irrelevant because the possibility is
there for them to strike someone with
their news and that's not something that
the United States wants to provoke or be
connected to being the catalyst for and
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis believes
and I agree with him that if Kim jong-un
did a retaliation the likes of which
he'd be capable of doing somewhere right
not necessarily on US soil but somewhere
that it would be quote a war more
serious in terms of human suffering than
anything we've seen since 1953 with a
potential death toll in the millions
imagine the dynamic in the White House
right I and again I happen to agree with
Tillerson and mattis a strike is a bad
idea for a number of reasons but there's
a case to be made for HR McMasters
position reasonable people competent
people people that are fit to serve and
make these types of decisions they could
have a reasonable conversation about
what the right approach with with North
Korea is but it's not like Trump is
sitting there with these guys
participating in the discussions like a
duck like an adult I imagine Pat that
Trump is sitting there while Tillerson
and mattis are arguing against a strike
and McMaster is outlining the possible
benefits I imagine Trump sitting there
with a TV remote in his hand watching
Fox and Friends saying yeah let's do it
let's bomb them give me the button to
press guys yeah at imagine he's leaning
towards McMasters side but it is
interesting how Tillerson in Madison
you're into the presidency have become
the voice of reason here I mean neither
are progressive champions to say the
least it's probably best that they stay
in this administration and further the
idea of Tillerson as someone in a
cabinet is absolutely horrified
in terms of what it means about the
kleptocracy right you're talking about a
lifelong oil executive whose philosophy
much like Trump's has been self
enrichment and greed and doing what's
best for him no matter who he has to
receive a medal from in the case of
Vladimir Putin
the fact that someone like that we say
this is one of the more reasonable
voices I don't want to normalize
Tatarstan but it's true compared to
Trump he is more reasonable CEO of
ExxonMobil who's probably only put in
there in the first place to secure that
five hundred billion dollar oil George
Russia or or whatever other one of his
different deals that he had on the table
was was attractive to Trump this is all
very scary news right that the news that
the president is this interested and
this focused on striking North Korea is
not good it's a strike that would be of
questionable benefit to anybody meaning
it's unclear if we did a strike like
this what the benefit is to us or to our
allies or to the civilians of North
Korea who I guess are we still claiming
Pat that we want to do what's best for
the civilians we are Korea I mean Trump
I guess is sort of saying that but I
don't know that anybody really believes
that and we've now learned and I guess
this is in the world of really blasted
silver linings I guess it's good that
there's someone trying to prevent Trump
from striking North Korea haphazardly
although it's unclear whether they're
going to be effective over the long term
not good
erratic irrational I don't know what
other adjectives I would assign to it
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership